investigación de cinco meses que cuenta
con los testimonios de 103 colaboradores
de la federación francesa de fútbol hoy
ha llegado a manos de la ministra de
deportes y de la federación sin embargo
sus conclusiones y los elementos que
retuvieron a los investigadores en
contra de noélix por acoso sexual y
moral han trascendido los últimos días a
través de la prensa básicamente entre
esos elementos se cuentan los mensajes
de texto y de voz enviados por el
dirigente a sus colaboradores mensajes
explícitos como la invitación a un plan
a tres o a beber una última botella o a
pasar bien la noche sin él alguna de sus
trabajadoras otras invitaciones a
ponerse falda a una de ellas durante un
viaje por ejemplo o algunas caricias
también efectuadas en la pierna de una
de ellas lo que también retienen los
investigadores es que estos mensajes se
enviaban de manera reiterada sobre todo
cuando él se encontraba bajo los efectos
del alcohol y que también él tenía todo
una estrategia y un sistema para enviar
textos muchas veces no era él quien los
escribía y tampoco había palabras de
sexo en esos mensajes sin embargo por la
hora en que los enviaba o la manera
reiterada en que lo hacía se puede
deducir que se trataba de acoso sexual y
moral los abogados de Noel también ya
han reaccionado a estas publicaciones
han dicho que su cliente estaba juzgado
De antemano y también han denunciado una
injerencia política de parte de la
ministra de deportes amelie udera casera
y también de los medios de comunicación
que han podido acceder a estos informes
el día viernes un comité ejecutivo
excepcional de la federación va a
analizar este informe y va a decidir el
futuro de noelecra